[Musica]
mi parlò dei diritti del cuore in questo
momento se ascoltasse il mio cuore va a
100.000 allora allora facciamo un gioco
questo pomeriggio
io non fingo di non essere emozionato e
voi mi perdonerete se la mia voce è un
po tremolante ma sto per raccontarvi la
storia della mia vita
mi chiamo carlo e 35 anni fa mi hanno
tirato fuori dalla pancia di mia madre
perché non respiravo più come dovevo qui
fuori però tutto è bellissimo i miei
genitori continuano a guardarmi a
piangere è un fratellino che mi fa
sempre le smorfie
credo di vivere in un bellissimo sogno
invece l'inizio della mia realtà
mi chiamo carlo 5 anni e adoro ballare
a mia madre ho detto che voglio fare il
ballerino
lei mi ha risposto che da grande
potrò diventare quello che voglio
allora da quel giorno ho imparato a
sognare ad occhi aperti
mi chiamo carlo bo 9 anni e a scuola mi
chiamano tutti quanti solai e gli ho
detto che il mio vero nome carlo ma loro
continuano a prendermi in giro e fa il
verso alla mia voce
allora la mia compagna di banco mi ha
suggerito di chiudere gli occhi e
sognare di essere un fantasma
solo cameron piace essere invisibile
mi chiamo carlo 14 anni ho finalmente la
mia prima fidanzatina a scuola hanno
smesso di prendermi in giro ma l'amore
non è come quello che descrivono nei
film io ci sto bene con lei ci diamo
tanti bacetti e tutti i sabati sera
andiamo a mangiare la pizza
ma io le farfalle allo stomaco
proprio non le sento
forse devo smetterla di sognare quegli
amori che leggo sui libri
mi chiamo carlo ho 19 anni e ho appena
detto mia madre che mi piacciono i
ragazzi
ci siamo abbracciati forte e lei è
scoppiata a piangere
io li ho promesso che sarebbe perso
sempre stata orgogliosa di me e lei mi
ha detto che non sarebbe cambiato nulla
che mi avrebbe continuato ad amare come
sempre anzi forse di più
solo che nei suoi occhi
leggevo
preoccupazione preoccupazione che non
avrei avuto le stesse opportunità di un
ragazzo etero
in quel momento
è come se i miei sogni si fossero
dimezzati tranciati perchè stavo
rinunciando al privilegio di costruirmi
una famiglia
quel giorno mia madre non se l'è sentita
di dirmi che da grande potrà diventare
chi voglio perché io vivo in un
bellissimo paese dove due uomini e due
donne che si vogliono bene non possono
sposarsi
vivono un paese dove l'unico amore via
merita di essere celebrato e quello tra
uomo e donna
allora quel giorno ho imparato a sognare
ad occhi chiusi perché non riuscivo più
a vedere la vita che volevo
ora qualcuno di voi si chiederà ma
perché hanno chiamato sto tizio a a
calcare il palco del decs riducano le
dicevo e vi posso assicurare che anche
io me lo sono chiesto tante volte anche
se sulla mia forma rarissima di artrite
psoriasica
potrei star qui a intrattenervi per i
prossimi quindici minuti con dettagli
esilaranti ma le articolazioni usurate
lasciamo da parte
che cosa ho da raccontarvi
in che cosa oggi posso essere di
ispirazione per capire insieme come
costruire la società di domani la
risposta è questa l'unica risposta
possibile probabilmente questa il
talento naturale nel prendermi cura dei
miei sogni e il fare di tutto per
realizzarli
a questo punto sembrano permettetemi
presenta un'altra volta giuro
quell'ultima per quanto il mio nome
conoscete già
mi chiamo carlo e sono esattamente nel
posto in cui avrei voluto essere dopo
anni ad ascoltare le storie a lieto fine
degli altri finalmente oggi posso
raccontarvi la mia
ho 35 anni
sono sposato e sono padre di due gemelli
sapete se io fossi nato a sacramento in
california
sarei stato semplicemente carlo sposato
con quel gran manzo di mio marito e
padre di due gemelli
probabilmente l'unica cosa interessante
della mia vita sarebbero stati appunto
le articolazioni usurate a nessuno
sarebbe interessato in che modo io sono
diventato genitore
e sarebbe bastato sapere che pago le
tasse
che tifo lakers che guarda opera e che
mi prendo cura dei gemelli come fossero
la cosa più importante della mia vita
e invece vivo in un paese bellissimo
nonostante io paghi le tasse tifi inter
e ammette ogni tanto di guardare anche
maria de filippi
vivo con una spilla conficcata nel petto
uscita con l'ossessione che qui da noi
se sei omosessuale non puoi essere
genitore
il giorno in cui
ho sposato christian a proposito
cristiana alzati in piedi fatti vedere
io lo avevo detto che era manzo e valore
il giorno in cui l'ho sposato ho
guardato mia madre e le ho detto è visto
ma alla fine anche io ho potuto urlare
davanti ad amici e parenti il mio amore
certo ho dovuto aspettare abbiamo dovuto
aspettare il 2016 e con una forma è
ridotta di matrimonio
l'hanno chiamata unione civile come se
l'amore tra due persone dello stesso
sesso dovesse celebrarsi in silenzio e
senza dare troppo nell'occhio
civilmente che già di borchie lustri né
cene stando al pride
ma da quel giorno ho ripreso nuovamente
a sognare ad occhi aperti
il giorno in cui i miei genitori hanno
conosciuto i gemelli
ho guardato mio padre io ho detto visto
pa ma alla fine anche tu sei diventato
nonno
e da quel momento
sogno tutti i giorni anche perché di
notte due giovani di tre anni si lascia
immaginare
vedete
oggi
sono qui in quanto
attivista della comunità lgbt che plus
ma sono qui soprattutto in quanto
attivista dei diritti umani perché qui
si parla di noi si parla di voi si
tratta si parla della nostra libertà di
scelta
si parla di persone e per questo oggi
vorrei concentrarmi
più sul come piuttosto che su cosa sono
riuscito a costruire
sperando che
la porticina che io ho aperto
nel 2050 diventi un grande portone
accessibile a tutti o meglio accessibile
a chiunque scelga di marcarlo
perché in fondo credo
che l'unica variabile che ci rende
davvero uguali
e la libertà di scelta
e se tutti non possiamo sognare la
stessa cosa allora vorrà dire che quel
diritto
appartiene a pochi ma non a tutti è
esclusivamente un privilegio
il giorno in cui sono inciampato
rovinosamente sul mio orientamento
sessuale me lo ricordo molto bene
facciamo questo gioco
alzi la mano chi si è innamorato del
proprio migliore amico o dalla propria
migliore amica
anche a me è successo
mi è successo ma non glie l'ho detto
e non solamente perchè non ha avuto il
coraggio di dirglielo ma semplicemente
perché
nessuno mi aveva detto che se io avessi
sentito quelle farfalle allo stomaco
quelle che svolazzano sull'intestino
crasso che si affollano sul pancreas
nessuno mi aveva detto che se le avessi
sentite per una persona del mio stesso
sesso
è stata una cosa normale
nessuno mi aveva detto che non c'era
niente di sbagliato
però la società i modelli che la società
mi suggeriva erano sempre gli stessi
madre padre uomo donna
immaginate di guardare la televisione
che trasmette un canale sempre con lo
stesso programma
quelli c'erano e quello doveva diventare
quelli erano gli unici due piani
percorribili le altre erano
semplicemente deviazioni che avrei
dovuto evitare per non ritrovarmi in una
strada dissestata buia sporca ostile
peccaminosa eccetera eccetera
allora per un periodo della mia vita
cosa ho fatto mi sono seduto sui binari
della normalità
perché così facevano tutti
vivendo esattamente come gli altri si
aspettavano che facessi e non che ci
stessi male ho avuto due relazioni
importanti con due ragazze e credevo
veramente di amarle certe sessioni di
pace a un certo punto era la bran tra
una automaticamente l'anestesia locale
e poi a 15 anni cioè dai libido talmente
tanto sensibile che alle farfalle allo
stomaco puoi anche rinunciare
bastava semplicemente accontentarsi e
mettere da parte dei propri sogni e
vivere secondo le aspettative degli
altri
solo che
ad un certo punto
[Musica]
ho detto basta
in questa vita ci stava stretto come se
stessi indossando una camicia di forza
ed è in quel momento che ho capito che
tutto il tempo impiegato a chiedere agli
altri il permesso per essere felice
era tempo che stavo sprecando per fare
in modo di esserlo e
mi sono detto sapete che c'è questo sono
io e di sbagliato c'è solamente chi
prova a dirci chi è come amare di
sbagliato c'è solamente chi prova a
farci vivere una vita che non ci
appartiene di sbagliato c'è solamente
tradire la nostra natura per
accontentare gli altri
ed è in quel momento che ho capito che
essere me stesso
avrebbe reso il mondo un posto migliore
ed enrica è partita la mia ricerca della
felicità
una ricerca che mi ha condotto nel posto
in cui avrei voluto vivere
un posto che conoscevo molto bene perché
è stato talmente tanto bello essere
figlio che mi sarebbe piaciuto tornarci
ma stavolta da padre un posto che però
nel nostro paese prevede delle
rigidissime barriere all'ingresso
soprattutto per chi come me
all'orientamento sessuale diverso
è un posto che per aggiungerlo ho dovuto
fare il giro del mondo non è esattamente
un eufemismo
[Musica]
nei miei figli i nostri figli sono nati
tramite la gestazione per altri negli
stati uniti una pratica che in paesi
come la california come nevada come il
canada è regolamentato da oltre
vent'anni ed è una scelta libera e
volontaria e consapevole
una scelta che coinvolge donne che
devono già essere madri e devono
dimostrare di essere ben al di sopra di
una certa soglia di povertà
una scelta che ha solamente l'obiettivo
di come dice la parola stessa generare
vita nel nostro caso due vite e che ci
ha permesso di essere una famiglia
allargata che oltrepassa i confini
fisici e ideologici di chi ci vede solo
una scelta dettata dall egoismo
quando rifletto al
non posso che pensare a
che tipo di mondo che tipo di società
vorrei consegnare ai gemelli ai miei
figli ai nostri figli
io nel
2050 pro
66 anni
cristian to miss a qualcosina di più
cambieranno tante cose
io per esempio per capelli grigio topo
probabilmente indosserò un paio di
occhiali da vista per riuscire e per
continuare a vedere bene la vita che
sono riuscito a costruirmi
però al di là della mia vecchiaia
galoppante sperando insomma che la
chioma sia volta come in questo momento
sono altri i cambiamenti che vorrei che
i miei figli che i nostri figli
riusciranno a vivere
nel 2050 mi piacerebbe che non
esistessero più
amori giusti e amori sbagliati
mi piacerebbe che non ci fosse più
distinzione tra amori da celebrare e
amori da tenere nascosti
vorrei che nel 2050 che nessuno più si
permettesse di dirci a casa vostra
fate quello che volete no signori non a
casa nostra io vorrei che chiunque si
sentisse sicuro al cinema per strada in
un vicolo dell'entroterra di un paesino
siciliano senza sentirsi gli occhi
puntati addosso della gente che si
attacca come amici la gina restituendo
ti quella sensazione di sporco e di
pericoloso
e 50 vorrei che la discussione sulla
legge contro l'omo lesbo b transfobia
fosse un lontanissimo lontanissimo
ricordo e che riusciremo a festeggiare
il trentennale di un importantissimo
atto di cittadinanza democratica perché
di questo si tratta
nel 2050 che vorrei mi piacerebbe che
non ci fosse più distinzione tra
famiglie di serie a e famiglie di serie
b
famiglie da aiutare le famiglie che non
meritano nemmeno di essere riconosciuta
nel 2050 mi piacerebbe che qualsiasi
tipologia di famiglia a prescindere
dalla composizione
venga tutelata protetta e rispettata e
vorrei che non fosse più necessario
adottare il figlio del partner e che
tutti i bambini nati all'estero tramite
gestazione per altri o fecondazione
assistita vengano riconosciuti
immediatamente in questo paese con due
genitori
in fondo l'unica cosa che vorrei è che
la sostanza valesse molto più della
forma
nel 2050 che vorrei mi piacerebbe che
non esistessero più attività sport
colori mansioni suddivise in maschi e
femmine
vorrei che mio figlio sebastian che
adora il rosa non rischi mai
di essere preso in giro semplicemente
perché ha scelto un colore la femmina
2050 vorrei che tutti i bambini avessero
la possibilità di dipingere il loro
mondo la loro vita con il colore che
vorranno
vorrei che tutti i padri che si prendono
cura dei propri figli non vengano mai
più chiamati ma mi basta ya famo più
basta
nel 2050 vorrei che esistesse un unico
congedo parentale senza dividerlo in
facoltativo obbligatorio madre padre uno
e chi è che chiunque possa scegliere
all'interno del proprio nucleo familiare
come spartirsi le mansioni dentro e
fuori le mura domani
nel 2050 vorrei che chiunque possa
sognare di essere chi vuole a
prescindere da ciò che ha dentro le
mutande e da chi ha scelto di amare
il 2050
vorrei che le donne fossero tutte vivere
libere di portare avanti una gravidanza
per altri o libera e di interromperla
vorrei che nessuna donna venga più
considerata egoista semplicemente perché
ha scelto di non avere dei figli
e vorrei che a nessuna donna venga più
chiesto se vuole o meno avere figli a un
colloquio di lavoro
basta davvero basta
vorrei che la libertà di scelta fosse
l'unica variabile che ci renda tutti
uguali
perché diversi lo siamo già ma liberi
ancora
nel 2050 vorrei che il mio talento nel
prendermi cura i sogni diventi
un'opportunità per chiunque lo voglia
per chiunque lo desideri e vorrei
semplicemente che le adozioni vengano
concesse ai single e alle coppie formate
da persone dello stesso sesso
infine l'ultimo augurio che vi faccio
che vi faccio che ci dobbiamo fare è che
nel 2050 prima del sesso prima
dell'orientamento sessuale prima della
nostra identità di genere
verremo considerati per quello che
davvero conta
esseri umani
grazie
[Applauso]